FAREED ZAKARIA: The price
is, of course, great,
because it's free.
This week, I'm not
recommending a book.
Premier Wen already did that.
But instead, I want you to
go back to school, for free.
And you don't have
to leave home.
This school is called
the Khan Academy.
It's an online classroom started
by former hedge fund manager
Sal Khan.
Khan makes videos of lessons
about everything from algebra
to venture capital and
everything in between.
2,000 lessons in all,
mostly math and science,
which have been watched
18 million times.
Bill Gates watches
them with his kids.
I want to recommend--
just to get
you started-- four
particular lessons, one
on the French Revolution, one
on so-called cupcake economics,
one on the Geithner plan
2.5, and one on that math
problem that vexed all of us
in high school, the passing
bicycles.
Take a look at this clip.
SALMAN KHAN: How many minutes
after Ann arrives at point B
will Betty arrive at point A?
So Betty was going
in this direction.
They meet right here.
And then she keeps
going and hits point A.
FAREED ZAKARIA: Didn't
get it in high school?
You will now.
Go to our website for
links to the lessons
I particularly like.
But they're really all good.
And now for the last look.